crises crises everywhere no no no I'm
not talking about starvation or war
genocide civil unrest rape murder or
poverty no no no what I'm talking about
is a tape in which a guy that we know
pays off women that he slept with talks
about paying off women they slept with
I'm talking about men copulating with
rubber dolls I'm talking about plastic
straws man the real problems we will
analyze the most pressing crises facing
our nation today and we will ask if
we've ever had it so good
then comedian and commentator Chad
Prather joins to discuss the electoral
landscape and finally Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez's brilliant media strategy I'm
going to complement her she's played
this very well plus the world's first
ever test-tube baby born today on this
day in history
I'm Michael Nobles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
a lot to get to so many crises and the
tape the big tape the big moment they
got Trump didn't they they finally got
him probably not before we get to that
we have to thank black rifle coffee a
wonderful sponsor black rifle coffee I
use them all the time it is delicious
are you did you ever find yourself
wincing at the weak taste of coffee from
those left-leaning preening straw
banning homeless shelter coffee houses
you know which one I'm talking about
do you ever find that well no more don't
do that at all you need black rifle
coffee you need look these guys were it
was founded by former Special Operations
vets it delivers the best roasts order
coffee right to your door this
guarantees you're getting fresh premium
coffee with every order you know with
there's been a big debate lately should
we own the libs
should we not own the libs the way you
could really own the libs is by owning
delicious coffee produced by veterans
that supports veteran causes and First
Responder causes and then you don't need
to go into that like homeless shelter
where they won't let you have straws
anymore down the street you know which
one I'm talking about you don't have to
do that in addition to great coffee and
great gear black rifle has coffee club
makes things really easy no lines just
great coffee shipped to your door every
month hassle free it's really good and
it helps out vets and first responders
go to black rifle coffee calm slash
coffe FA Co V Fe Fe get 15% off your
first or 15% off your order period don't
say I never did nothing for you black
rifle coffee calm slash coffe FA CE o VF
e Fe coffee coffee coffee coffee FA
Black rifle coffee dot gum slash coffe
fa it is a really good coffee it is
where I use it all the time
okay let's get to the big stuff the big
topic today we're talking about the tape
Michael Cohen did he flip did Fredo flip
I know it was you Michael never take
sides against the family again was it
let's see let's listen to the bombshell
tape the CNN got and that all the
mainstream media outlets are reporting
on what it means for Trump what it means
for the Muller investigation what it
means for all of this and all of the
terrible crises in our country here is
the Michael Cohen super secret Donald
Trump tape I've spoken to Alan
weiselberger about
to set the whole thing up with funding
yes and it's all the stuff I need to
open up a company for the transfer of
all of that info regarding our friend
David you know so that I'm gonna do that
right away I've actually come up with me
so I'm all over that and I spoke to Alan
about it when it comes time for the
financing which will be easy listen what
financing will have to do so I got no no
okay
there it is and so you can hear they're
making a lot out of this they say okay
we got to pay are we gonna pay and Trump
you can't hear because it's all muffled
says cash and Cohen says no no no no
we're gonna pay and Trump says check
right so what they're alleging what
Michael Cohen's lawyer is alleging what
the anti-trump forces are alleging is
that Trump wanted to pay cash to pay off
these girls that he had allegedly slept
with and Cohen said no no no no no but
when you hear the tape it's pretty clear
he's saying annoy with cash don't pay
with cash is now what Trump's team is
saying and that seems plausible look I I
will admit when President Trump is a
twisting language a little bit you know
in Helsinki he said I meant to say
wouldn't but I said would I this is not
one of those cases this is one it is
clearly saying something oh no no no
cash no no no I got this check it does
it don't you're not gonna pay with cash
no no no you pay with cheque right
okay so that's fine now this is the big
bombshell right it comes out it actually
tells us a lot about Trump's media
strategy but let's check in on the
legality of all this does this
constitute a crime you know there's a
girly-girl alleges that President Trump
slept with her and he's basically before
the election he's just paying these
people off to keep quiet they're a
couple of things that are pretty funny
about this one it reminds me of that
Mark Wahlberg movie for brothers where
they say I'll try to clean up the
language they say you don't pay a ho to
sleep with you you pay her to go home
and that's what we're pretty interesting
in this story both with stormy Daniels
and Karen McDougal the new Playboy
Playmate that allegedly slept with Trump
ten years ago
they say that they after their romantic
tryst Trump offered to pay them and both
stormy Daniels and Karen McDougal when
they're talking to the media they say I
was so offended by this he I'm not that
kind of girl I can't believe you would
call me that kind of girl
to pay me to sleep with me I can't
believe you would allege that but then
then they took all the money later isn't
that interesting they said you know they
they said no I don't hand me an envelope
full of money that makes me feel like a
prostitute I want you to hand me a lot
lot more money later on to keep quiet
then I won't feel like a prostitute it's
pretty funny because you know I don't
know what was Trump gonna pay them to
sleep with them I can't imagine that
much money but then later on they say no
no I don't want that money I want
$150,000 to keep quiet
so really it's funny because they're all
these tears on camera oh I cried I
couldn't believe he thought that I would
accept money because I had sex with him
and I said well darling didn't you
accept $150,000 well yeah but that was
different because that was a little
later okay fine
was there a crime committed that's the
question we talked to a wonderful
brilliant law Professor Alan Dershowitz
on the show last week here as Alan
Dershowitz weighing in on whether this
demonstrates a crime no it sounds very
plausible especially since they did seem
to use the word plural that perhaps what
the president and Cohen were discussing
is in the run-up to the election there
were probably going to be lots of people
who will come and demand cash in order
not to embarrass the president just
before the election and they were
discussing how to set up a corporation
to make payments if necessary to keep it
from influencing the election that
happens all the time that happens all
the time Dershowitz this point is this
doesn't demonstrate a crime he's now
there the one flipside one argument that
some of the anti-trump people are making
is that this is similar to John Edwards
you remember John Edwards former senator
or vice presidential candidate Democrat
he he was paying paying off his mistress
and this was a campaign finance
violation and it really got him for it
but if that is the the line that they're
drawing if that's the analogy here this
bodes very well for Donald Trump because
the prosecution never got John Edwards
he never he
never convicted of anything that's what
that worked out just fine for him and
what really hurt John Edwards is he
portrayed himself as this good Christian
man as upright citizen that's wonderful
you know and then it turns out he was
cheating with this mistress on his wife
who was dying of cancer that really blew
up his entire career obviously with
Donald Trump you don't have that problem
what's the new information President
Trump
paid off women that allege that he slept
with them president Trump is bragged
about that there's no new information
conveyed it's not going to destroy his
political career certainly and what's
the legal problem if John Edwards wasn't
convicted for these crimes what how are
they going to get Donald Trump on this
so half decide with Alan Dershowitz here
this can't be this doesn't seem to
present a really big issue for him it
doesn't presume to present any new
information either we know that he slept
with these women ten years ago we know
that he likes Playboy Playmates
okay no new information now this brings
up the next question why did he allow
this tape to come out because the media
aren't really reporting on this
President Trump has attorney-client
privilege here these were tapes Michael
Cohen recorded him his lawyer recorded
this conversation why did Trump waive
attorney-client privilege Trump allowed
this tape to come out well there are a
few reasons
clearly President Trump doesn't think
that this is going to kill him if he
thought this was going to kill him he
wouldn't have waived attorney-client
privilege Trump is now coming out and
playing this against Michael Cohen so he
tweeted out he said what kind of lawyer
would tape apply him so sad is this a
first never heard of it before
why was the tape so abruptly terminated
well I was presumably saying positive
things I hear there are other clients
and many reporters that are taped can
this be so too bad
so he's he's insinuating that Michael
Cohen as a bad lawyer he's a crooked
lawyer there's something wrong with him
fair enough I don't know what kind of
lawyer tapes his client like that and
would betray his benefactor I mean you
know Dante puts the people who betray
their benefactors in the lowest circle
of hell this is a really bad thing and
Michael Cohen is apparently turning on
Trump he says the truth is gonna come
out he's hired Lanny Davis were going
after Donald Trump so it does raise
questions about Cohen and raises
questions about his integrity if he if
he has any integrity I don't know that
people ever thought he had integrity but
the fact that he would tape Trump the
fact that he's turning against his
benefactor really does raise those
questions and so I think that plays to
Trump's advantage in all of this but
doesn't everything else play to Trump's
advantage here the the there was public
polling that shows that the vast
majority of Americans do not care about
the stormy Daniels story they don't care
about it at all there's also there was a
new poll out from Quinnipiac it showed
that twenty point one percent of the
entire American electorate
considers the mainstream media the enemy
of the people if they consider this
story ginned up by the media this is a
media and non traversée
21 percent of all voters and 18 percent
of independents so that number holds
strong there that seems pretty strong
you know I was listening to Rush
Limbaugh earlier who is one of the best
observers of politics of course but he
said without this sex stuff the stormy
Daniels all of the in Mulder
investigation
he thinks that president Trump's
approval rating could be at 60% it's
already very high it's already at 45%
but it could be at 60 I have to disagree
with Rush here I'm not sure about that I
think if if people weren't focused on
the sex stuff if people weren't focused
on Russia on the Moller investigation
the witch-hunt they'd be focused on
something else they gin up some other
crisis they've try to focus on the
border the you know the the people being
ripped from their families at the border
or they'd focus on some company going
out of business even though we have a
record low unemployment and a booming
economy they just focus on other real
things and for President Trump this is
manageable the sex stuff is manageable
it doesn't really hurt him it's already
hurt him whatever effect that's gonna
have on him it's already have this
Russia investigation it doesn't hurt him
public polling consistently shows the
American people don't care about Russia
don't care about stormy Daniels don't
care or the new girl Karen McDougal
I do google her name because I don't
even who cares it's just kind of
floating in the air not not the worst
thing in the world so I I do i I do want
to find out how intentional this is is
this really the you know the lawyer
turning on Trump and Trump turning on
the lawyer it's gonna or is this more
good TV I you know everything with
Donald Trump is it seems to be a
manipulation of the media I'm not saying
he plays for teach
I'm not saying he's met her dick or
something I'm saying that he's really
good at the media he has been for
decades and this could be another
example of this as long as the spotlight
is on the sex and the Russia it's not on
other things and president Trump gets to
go on with his with his very effective
administration you know there's a reason
that his approval rating is so high it's
a 45% and they seem to be doing
something right here to help me analyze
this maybe I'm just looking at the glass
half-full here let's bring on it Chad
Prather you know Chad Prather from his
viral video it's pretty where you first
saw him unapologetically southern you
might have seen him do a hit with me on
Fox and Friends and you might know him
from the Chad pray their show his
podcast he's got a comedy tour going on
let's bring on Chad you there hey
Michael good to hear from you man good
to see you again Chad thanks for coming
on I appreciate it so you're on the road
right now is that right you're you're
doing your comedy tour I am so it's
always great when your assistant or
white male walking around San Jose with
a cowboy hat on he gets some eyes you
know I love saying hoo hoo I love saying
who gets triggered yeah just all of them
yeah that's another good example of
owning the libs which I strongly
encourage I'm a big proponent of that I
want to know with this
Trump stuff you are touring around
you're on the road you're you're in
places that constitute sometimes real
America how do you think this plays the
tape and the Michael Cohen and the
Muller investigation and this sex and
the Russia and the blah blah blah what
is your sense do people care about this
or they really worked up about this how
is Trump playing it not a bit there you
know people are gonna come to my shows
and it doesn't matter it's funny Michael
because I've done shows now I've got two
shows tonight tomorrow night in San Jose
California obviously not a conservative
bastion in America I've got I've had
sold-out shows in Portland Oregon Eugene
Medford Oregon Seattle Washington New
York New Jersey you get my point
and people drive in to these places and
they sit down and they enjoy a show and
not a single person is distracted by
these things yeah occasionally you might
hear somebody who says I wish the
president wouldn't tweet that you know
some some ladies ring in her hands god I
just wish you wouldn't do that but all
that's just that's just Trump and I
think that's everybody's attitude you
know the thing is we what we're facing
and you know this so well
it's just distractions and if it wasn't
this distraction it would be another
distraction and that's what that's what
the media and and the left is
continually berating out here is can we
put out another's distraction and I
think at this point really and I've said
this over and over again it gets me in
trouble it's become white noise people
say I can't believe you don't care more
about this now that's just white noise
it's just a buzz Caucasian noise you
mean Caucasian pretty much you know it
is I do think it's all just noise out
there and I look at the other crises the
big crises of the day one of them is
straws apparently if people are using
too many straws this is a big concern
for people people are having sex with
with rubber doll that's another one and
I have to wonder is this the most
decadent time in the history of the
world
does anybody have any actual problem
it's pretty amazing I mean when they're
saying that that mankind or as Trudeau
would say people kind is going to be
finished in in 50 years if we don't stop
using plastic straws like are you really
drumming up a problem in does anyone
care that they are dismantling nuclear
facilities in North Korea right now I
mean are we really that ready I had I
had a mentor of mine whose father-in-law
passed away 20 years ago and when they
were developing this new development in
my hometown they were tearing up they
were cutting down all these trees to
build and he was so worried just
wringing his hands he drive by said
what's gonna happen when we don't have
any more trees and my mentor told him
one day he said well there will be
enough wood to build a box to put you in
it
and put you in the ground and sure
enough 25 years ago that's what happened
and blesses our so everybody you know
the sky is falling the sky is falling
it's absolutely ridiculous and then KOMO
comes out with this new tape and all
that and it's such a you know nothing
there's absolutely nothing there is
nothing to it they were bored with it
that's that's what I think it is I think
all of this actually comes up because
we're bored if we had real problems you
wouldn't be worrying about the straws
you know I had my priest Father Rutger
come on the other day he said when the
Barbarian invades there are no safe
spaces you can't worry about these
little tiny things anymore what is it
have Americans grown soft I'm reminded
of Teddy Roosevelt saying Americans are
soft we need a war in some action
struggle to make people serious again
what is it as the country just going to
soft you know if you go back to the
idealism of say 1914 and right at the as
the precursor to World War one everybody
was looking in the mirror and saying to
themselves over and over and every day
in every way I'm getting better and they
have this ideal at view of the world
World War one hit and it was for
devastating years and everyone was
affected by especially Europe you know
ten million men are dead in France and
all of a sudden people come marching
back for more and they see what real
tragedy is like and I think we're living
in a day where we don't understand what
real tragedy is anymore we don't
understand yes yes we see the things
because the bad news is constantly
paraded in front of us 24/7 and like you
said it's it makes for quote good TV
tragedy and bad things make for good TV
but people haven't faced anything that
has toughened us up so now you know you
read a magazine a cover that says the
rise of the beta male I mean are you
kidding me this is what we're talking
about this is what we're discussing
you'll really arrive it's more like a
more of a slouching of the beta male
sort of like often I was into it ease
into it you know yes yes yes slaves yes
you know this reminds me Steven Pinker
has this book out enlightenment now and
he talks about this I saw him give a
lecture on this in Orange County which
is that everything materially is better
diseases down war is down life
expectancy is up infant mortality is
down poverty is down starvation is down
everything materially is getting better
and people are getting more depressed
they're loose they're getting more
anxious they're getting more neurotic
they're the suicide rate is going up
if this doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense to Steven Pinker or to other
people who are atheists or materialists
but it seems to me they're missing the
cultural aspect so materially everything
might be getting better we're getting
cheap t-shirts from China and you know
we get a movie pass and get to see
movies for free and like all of that is
great but in a cultural level there does
seem to be some decay are you seeing
that and do you think there is any way
to to reverse that trend I I think
people are disillusioned I think they're
disengaged from reality
and you know we we live within a world
where the statistic one of the highest
growing demographics in America today
are people turning 100 I mean people are
living longer they're doing but yet but
yet you have an epidemic of opioid
crisis and you have an epidemic of
suicides amongst teenagers and these
things because there is this sense of
okla sness i always say yeah and i'll
take all the heat for it i think that
there has to be a return to a foundation
of faith both faith in God faith in
yourself faith in the people around you
faith in the culture faith in the
Constitution we could list these things
out there there's a reason America has
done what it's done the last 250 years
even with the scars even with the things
we've done wrong the things in our
history that we need to mend heal in a
race we still have done a lot of things
right and we have to go back and have
faith in that faith in the process and
it's amazing to me people who want to
come along and they want to say well the
only reason Trump won is but those are
the electoral college
well that's the only reason any
president in history everyone the
presidency that that's the process and
then you want to say well you know we're
living in a day and age where you know
we maybe we need to look at democratic
socialism and that you know that's
that's not an answer why are you going
to change a process that's worked so
well and go embrace something that
historically has proven itself to be
tragic just so you can now be different
so I is there hope for it I think it's
gonna take a massive amount a massive
amount of of coming back in together to
dialogue and discuss you know it and
I've said this the old adage the example
of a healthy bird has two healthy wings
and it flies in a direction if you have
one big wing on one side or the other
it's just gonna fly in circles and not
get anywhere but I think the tendency is
everybody wants to interpret one another
as being out on the tips of the wings we
got to get back into the vitality of the
bird if you will get right into where
the heart beat in the end of in the body
and the muscle and the moment moving the
motion in the brain is and until people
are willing to do that because you know
I say it all the time I say we live in
this world where we don't know each
other anymore
and we have a real world you don't walk
into the average restaurant you know I'm
in LA all the time I'm working on
projects in LA I go to LA just like this
cowboy hat on walking through WeHo and
and people give me the look but I can
walk in a restaurant we don't
immediately start having a conversation
or a debate about politics hi how are
you
good to see it we don't do that but yet
we think we can go in at the end of the
afternoon and we drive in our garage the
door goes down we go in we pull out our
device and we think we can debate
politics with a stranger from seven
states away and that be effective it's
just not we've lost the concept of being
neighbors and we don't know each other
anymore and that's just a shame that's
what's got to change that is so true
this is actually why ironically I'm
defending the you know owning the libs
against some of the attacks on it is not
because we need to be mean to our
countrymen who see things wrongly but
it's because comedy is a great tool
comedy is the great tool to do this you
know you do it you know you can either
yell at people and be really angry or
whatever but owning the libs is when you
tell a joke owning the libs is when you
smack down some stupid idea and it's
funny that creates some absurdity it
shows some incongruent and that's fun
I'd much rather convince my fellow
countrymen to come over to my point of
view by laughing and having a little joy
a little joy goes a long way and you're
you're literally doing that I mean you
are taking comedy and you're going to
Portland and you're going to New Jersey
how is one how's the tour going where
can people find you and and do you think
that the left which has been so
humorless for a while is going to get
their sense of humor back I think
they're gonna have to you know we live
in a day and age where a guy who's who's
simple and ingenious as Jerry Seinfeld
refuses to go on a college campus and do
comedy anymore because he knows that
everybody gets offended that's a shame
but I the tours going great you can find
dates at watched addcom and and people
are packing these theatres it's really
great all the way across the country and
it's been a lot of fun to watch because
I'm I am an equal opportunity offender
if I see something worth making fun of
I'm gonna make fun of it if whether it's
you know making a joke about the
worthlessness of Barack Obama giving a
keynote speech at the NRA convention or
you know the fact that Donald Trump is
married to a supermodel because of his
money you know I get the groans from
that and I'm like but come on that woman
never said Oh Donald I love your hair
you know she been trying to rub her
fingers through it in the hairspray
hold on her fingers you got to be able
to poke fun at that stuff and laugh at
it if you don't you're gonna wind up
crying because I think that laughing is
is a great you
fire but you know the thing the thing is
we've lost a culture of comedy because
of this culture of offended 'no stand
people can't you know it's comedy for
comedy sake is okay i I even want to
defend a lot of these things that we
come out and we get on to people about
say yeah but it's being done in the vein
of comedy you know in let it go just let
it go don't be so sensitive to it
anymore so I tell people learn how to
laugh I think it was Horace Walpole said
life is a comedy to the man who thinks
and a tragedies the man who feels but
facts don't care about your feelings
folks so lighten up and laugh Chad go to
watch Chad calm check out the Chad
Prather show I got to let you go you get
back on the road and keep offending
everybody out there in San Jose yeah
well good to talk to you I have to have
you back on you too see you soon Michael
that's a good perspective that's that's
like you know guys take yourself a
little lightly every so often the reason
surgeon said this the reason that angels
can fly is because they can take
themselves lightly if you're so heavy
and weigh down all the time you're not
going to have a good life and and this
brings us to our crises all of the
crises that we're in right now like the
straw crisis this is if you can't laugh
at the straw crisis what are you doing
but they take it very seriously the left
right now is banning plastic drinking
straws right now in San Francisco
they've banned plastic drinking straws
in Santa Barbara not too far up from us
I was just up there a couple weeks ago
they've they've banned waiters at
restaurants from giving out plastic
drinking straws they're going to enforce
this with a $1,000 fine or six months in
jail so if you go to a restaurant in
Santa Barbara you are given a plastic
drinking straw that waiter can go to
jail for six months and or get a
thousand dollar fine and it compounds on
itself it's not like that's the limit if
you go with your family you sit down
it's a table of four that guy gives you
people straws in your water
this guy could go to jail for two years
if you have a party in there
you know you you you have a party you
invite your big family you know you get
a let's say it's forty people or
something that guy's doing 20 years in
the clink because he gave out plastic
drinking straws that is some crazy stuff
now simultaneously it's no longer a
felony in California to knowingly give
somebody aids
that's no longer a felony that's not a
crime give somebody aids that's fine
give them a plastic drinking straw so
they can enjoy their drink like a
civilized person you go to jail and you
pay and you pay money in New York City
New York has decriminalized public
urination so you go to California you
can give somebody aids go to New York
City you can urinate in the middle of
the street that's okay if you give
somebody a plastic drinking straw that
is the crime these are really backwards
priorities here in California they just
tried to pass a bill to decriminalize
heroin to allow people to shoot up
heroin in certain safe places but you
can't have drinking straws this is a
really backwards thing and it's a
culture that's obviously turned upside
down you know in the way this whole
thing started by the way is because of a
nine-year-old kid I kid you not a
nine-year-old kid didn't like that
people were using drinking straws he
thought that was wasteful he had been
indoctrinated into some environmentalist
thing so he called some restaurants and
made up this number he said we use 500
million straws a day in the United
States maybe I don't know if that's true
and now as a result there's this major
anti straw movement it's this it's that
urging the left to just invent crises to
invent problems it has to do with their
politics you know the way the Left views
politics the way that rationalists view
politics is they just see its problem
after problem after problem and we just
we always need a problem and you always
need a solution that's all politics is
conservatives tend to take a nicer view
of politics a more broad view politics
is a political tradition we're living
through a political tradition we can
rely on institutions we can rely on
traditions to get us through our
politics it's not the foremost thing in
life but when you have to rationalize
everything in politics like the left
does and some elements of the right then
all of a sudden it's every little
problem and when things are going too
well when when you know everything is
tickety-boo to quote Indra Clavin then
you have to make up problems like this
problem of the drinking straws and you
become very hysterical case in point is
one senator Cory Booker do I have to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube where
can I get to a Cory Booker I get to Cory
Booker okay good here it was Cory Booker
the The Crying of Senator in the United
States here is Cory Booker talking about
the day
sure of appointing Brett Kavanaugh to
the Supreme Court just what they should
know to understand then in the moral
moment there is no there is no neutral
in a moment
there's no bystanders you are either
complicit in the evil you aren't either
contributing to the wrong or you are
fighting against there's a save from the
Abraham preface in one of the Psalms it
says they don't meet walk through the
valley of the shadow of death we don't
walk you through the valley of the
shadow of death but that doesn't say
though I sit in the valley of the shadow
of death
it doesn't fit I'm watching on the
sidelines of evaluate it says I'm
walking through the valley of the shadow
of death it's just I am taking agency I
make it through this crisis so I
understand cory booker is really turning
the hysteria up to 11 you know there's a
line on the internet which is everybody
I don't like his Hitler that's how
people engage in Internet discourse cory
booker sees your everybody I don't like
his Hitler and he raises you and
everybody I don't like his Satan he is
turning it up to say you are evil and
what what is the evil act if you are
okay with a completely boring you know
sort of Brooks Brothers tie-wearing
judge who went to Yale Law School if
you're if you're okay with that guy
being a judge he's already a judge has
been a judge for a long time if you're
okay with him being a judge you're evil
you're Satan you're evil and it's so
it's so funny in the background of this
video of Elizabeth Warren and a couple
other 60 year old women white women
standing there just like yeah preach aim
yeah like not not a good look ladies
doesn't doesn't really look great not
you know I'm not feeling electricity
going through here and Cory Booker look
this is a very cynical move by Cory he's
trying to position himself for 2020 and
so he's turned up this emotion thing he
he I remember in one of the hearings he
said I cried tears of rage and is all
this yelling and emotionalism he used to
be a kind of normal guy by the way he
used to be the guy who in 2012 was
defending Mitt Romney he said old Mitt
Romney's not that bad this was the guy
when they were saying MIT Romney was the
devil the last time the Democrats had a
devil he said oh he's not that bad he's
okay let's come on everybody take it
down but Cory is now thinking that his
only ticket to the White House in 2020
is if he becomes one of these screeching
emotional hysterical people the shtick
does not play well he's just not good at
it other politicians are good at that
Obama was pretty good about pulling on
the heartstrings Cory Booker is not this
is not his strength if he wants to have
a prayer at the White House he's he's
got to try something else this is not
not gonna work that they have to create
this crisis they've backed themselves
into this corner where there is a crisis
and everything has to turn it up turn it
up turn it up to 11 but nobody really
believes that nobody thinks that Brett
Kavanaugh is the devil nobody thinks
that appointing a judge to a court is
that's the end of the you know that
Satan's victory over his eternal victory
over the world no nobody thinks that and
and so it doesn't ring true I don't I
don't really see this strategy working
well for for Democrats in the future but
they're gonna they're gonna have to do
it the only person who's actually sort
of pivoting and and doing it pretty
wisely is Alexandria Ocasio Cortes we'll
get to that a little bit later still a
lot to get to the last important crisis
is the sexbots sexbots are taking over
the world they might turn us into an
endangered species that's a new report
out today that the Japanese might become
any danger dre s-- because of the
prevalence of sex robots there we'll
talk about that we'll talk about the
first test-tube baby born on this day in
history in 1978 what that gets to and
why alexandria Ocasio cortez made a
brilliant media move in turning on
turning on Ali's Stuckey or friend of
the show we'll explain how that happened
but you got to go to
I'm sorry what do you want me to do go
to daily wire.com we have a lot more to
get to it's 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
under Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you have to ask questions
and the mailbag get them in that will be
tomorrow you blah blah blah blah blah
you get this get you get them up by the
way a pretty soon I don't know I haven't
talked to the department that makes
these tumblers yet we need to start
including plastic straws in them I know
that you can sip it you know but that's
what it tastes good when you sip it we
need to and maybe we'll put two plastic
straws in them and see you go over get
the it'll be like it'll be a meta
leftist year's tumbler it itself will
produce the leftist tears it will be a
perpetual motion machine all that for
your daily wiring membership go to daily
wire comm we'll be right back with a lot
more
sexbots this is the last decadent crisis
that we've got to deal with today before
we get to the cultural aspect at the
heart of all of this talk about a
decadent crisis the big crisis plaguing
mankind right now is that we created
robots to have sex with and we're doing
it too much that this is endangering the
population of Japan always Japan you
know those guys are always a little
ahead of the curve aren't they they had
VCRs or produce all this technology and
now they're having sex with all of the
technology that they've created so this
is the the problem sex robots are now
available to people they're not totally
widely used yet but in Japan they've
really taken a liking to them Japan has
had a declining population for a long
time now they're below replacement rate
and for the first time in history now
for the first time in recent history
they're their birth rate is below the
million mark the and it's below
replacement so what's happening is in
Japan men prefer to have sex with
silicon devices rather than with their
wives we've heard this for years two men
public opinion poll showed that men
would prefer to look at pornography than
to go out and be with an actual woman
and this makes perfect sense it actually
does make perfect sense because when
you're with a woman she's a person you
know so
she has desires demands rights things
you know you've got a kind of if you
know unless you're a total psychopath
you've got to kind of do how do you feel
do you like this okay I don't know you
know you got to buy them dinner you
don't have to buy a robot dinner and
it's this utter narcissus I mean is this
utter egotism and selfishness - one -
just take pornography over a woman but
then certainly this robot I mean it is a
really perverse thing and we can joke
about it it's a ridiculous news story
but it is a real fear because if men can
just have sex with robots a good number
of them are going to do it you know the
robots okay they're they're a little
more flexible I mean you know the list
of potential advantages goes on and on
and on but it's a real worry
it brings up bioethical concerns not a
joke I mean they're people say the
libertarian point of view is oh let
people do whatever they want let people
come on just freedom just let people do
whatever they want that isn't freedom
and I don't think conservatives should
advocate that kind of freedom
conservatives from the time of Edmund
Burke certainly onward have advocated
ordered Liberty that word ordered is
important not Liberty nism not just like
sex drugs and rock and roll but liberal
a true Liberty and you and you know
Christ says the man who sends us a slave
to sin and there's this connection
between sin and vice and your freedom if
you are caught if you're addicted to
some substance then you're not really
free are you because that appetite is
controlling you the reason that you have
a classical education is to instead to
instill virtues in you and to practice
the virtues and to be able to not become
a slave to sins like this and that's the
case with these sex robots that it's
it's just another addiction it's like
heroin it's like meth pornography as an
addiction it's booze whatever whatever
pick your poison
those are addictions and if you're
addicted to something then you're not
really free oh I don't know if there
will be some law passed against this I
don't know it probably will require a
lot more than a law probably will
require an education and a moral
education but right now in the West
around the world immoral or moral senses
really decayed it's really rotted and
the right is a little bit guilty of this
too when we buy into that ridiculous
libertarian notion of oh you know man
whatever if it doesn't hurt anyone else
just do it no that's not how you have a
good society John Adams said that the
United States is only built for a moral
and religious people you can't have
Liberty if you're not going to govern
yourself someone will instill order
either you can order yourself and
discipline yourself and carry yourself
like an adult or the government's going
to do it for you but order will be
preserved we will not have chaos Society
will not tolerate that so a little word
of warning as I know I know what you're
thinking out there you you behind that
computer screen you demographically
speaking most likely young male viewer
of this program you are thinking on a
sex robot that doesn't sound so bad
Oh
I wonder if they could do oh they can't
do that thing over there were some real
pitfalls here it's a real a real worry
and and we've had bioethical concerns
like this before that we haven't dealt
with very seriously and and you know
it's in those small things that the rock
begins this brings us to this day in
history because on this day in history
in 1978 the first test-tube baby was
conceived this is what it was the baby's
name
Louise joy brown first baby conceived
artificially and people all wonder they
said is this okay is this ethical what
do we do I will there be problems
will there be birth defects will they be
sterile whatever now in vitro
fertilization exists all over the place
this is a mainstream procedure people
don't seem to have much of a problem
with it the Catholic Church still frowns
on it the Catholic Church still
prohibits it but a lot of even other
Protestant organizations they say it's
okay and we haven't dealt with the
ethical implications of this I mean
infertility is a multi-billion dollar
industry just the business of egg
donations is a multi-billion dollar
industry to say nothing of all of the
other procedures and look at the
procedure itself IVF is very expensive
it's can cost twenty five thousand
dollars to create a child through this
process and there are some problems that
come along with it you know there's
twice the rate of birth defects
according to one study that was
published in the New England Medical
Journal and but then there's the the
question of pro-life because so
frequently IVF involves the destruction
of embryos of little babies that have
been conceived and the pro-life movement
doesn't talk about it a whole lot but
they should there was a wopo piece about
this and they said how come the
pro-lifers don't talk about in vitro
fertilization when you do in vitro
fertilization because it's so expensive
usually they'll fertilize four to eight
eggs and so you'll you'll conceive four
to eight little babies and you'll freeze
some of them and then you'll implant the
other so if you implant let's say you
implant four in the womb then you see
which ones take some of them
statistically speaking won't take and
they'll be destroyed and then if they
all take what frequently happens is
selective abortion
so then the parents will say oh no well
we don't want four so let's kill off
three of them and oh let's do it by okay
we don't want them to have that disease
okay cuz you've been screened for these
things now we don't want it to be that
gender we don't want to write we don't
want you you can make a design or baby
we're much further along to that as
possible so much further along to that
than we'd like to admit to ourselves so
you've got this situation where we're
protesting against Planned Parenthood
because they're killing babies in the
womb but we're not concerned about this
process IVF because it's so nice we only
see the nice stories on the news Oh a
couple that couldn't conceive now they
can conceive a child and isn't that nice
I know people who were test-tube babies
you think I like my friend so I I think
this process should be allowed to
continue but there is a cost to this I
mean you are conceiving children and
killing them or donating them to medical
research or locking them in a way in a
freezer forever and if you really
believe that life begins at conception
if you believe that some insolvent
happens at that point then you're
freezing them away forever that is a
pretty horrific thing yeah but we don't
think through these easily enough we
only think about the nice aspect or the
frivolous aspect or the glib aspect oh
you know oh it's a sex robot who cares
well let the guy let the guys in Japan
have fun there are implications there
were unintended consequences about this
and when you have a moral regime that is
so insane if you've got a moral
structure that basically today in the
West is if it feels good do it then
you're not going to be able to think
through those things and you could have
it could have really disastrous effects
all of the futurists that we talked to
all of these you know public
intellectuals who come out and they say
I'm terrified about AI I'm terrified
about the extinction of the human
species I'm terrified about this I'm
terrified about that perhaps we should
start taking that seriously because
otherwise we're going to end up in a
position where you've you've got people
blathering like Cory Booker you know
about evil and the evil and the evil but
we don't see the evil right in front of
our face which is usually the case
alright enough about IVF I know I've got
to go very soon before I go I've got I
want to end on a happy note which is the
mainstream media meltdown over Ali
Stuckey's video making fun of Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes so the mainstream media
went bomb
with this alley Stuckey we played the
video yesterday she did this obvious
satire video of Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez's stupid interview with Margaret
Hoover you could tell it obviously was
satire was on a different set she was
very different clothing than the woman
in the video the the other video the
first video had gone completely viral
everybody had already seen that but what
the mainstream media did is instead of
saying okay you know this parody
whatever we liked it or we didn't like
it or what what have you they decided to
call it fake news they played dumb they
were obtuse they said this wasn't satire
this was a fake in tribute designed to
deceive people so the Washington Post
ran the headline they said after a fake
interview of Alexandria Cassio Cortez
went viral its maker said it was satire
what they said was satire in the first
place she when they posted it there was
a little winky emoji the intercept
another website said fake interview with
Alexandria Cassio Cortez was satire not
hoax conservative pundit says as though
you know this is a big conspiracy as
though Allie Stuckey you know is was
trying to deceive people which obviously
isn't the case the Washington Times said
Alexandria Cassio Cortes calls out Allie
Stuckey for parody interview and it's
true aquezio Cortez is calling her out
for it you know The Verge a million
Facebook users watched a video that
blurs the line between bad satire and
fake news no it was just funny satire
doesn't blur any line it wasn't bad
with it's just wasn't fake news and then
ago the rap gets even better they say
see our TV host of doctored Ocasio
Cortez video doubles down of doctored
what doctored video it was satire and
then ocasion Cortez comes with her punch
and she landed it this was a good punch
she said Republicans are so scared of me
that they're faking videos and
presenting them as real on Facebook
because they can't deal with reality
anymore here's one bonafide truth
election day is November 6th which I
don't actually don't know if that's true
this year we should look that up that'd
be I would not put it past okay SEO
Cortes to get the election day wrong in
that but okay okay honey all right okay
zo Cortez I'm we're not if we're
of you here's my proof of that you are
welcome on my show anytime please come
on my show it'll be live or live to tape
we won't we won't dr. anything we can
just have a frank conversation you and
me we come from very similar backgrounds
both poor you know grew up in poor
neighborhoods in New York and we were
little babies and then before elementary
school move to the suburbs we grew up
one town away from one another
Yorktown Heights and Bedford Hills went
to adjacent high schools we have such a
similar background it'll be a fair fight
just come on just do it I mean the
difference is you lied about your
upbringing and I didn't lie about mine
but just come on I won't be afraid you
won't be afraid of me I won't be afraid
of you will we'll have a discussion
about democratic socialism come on the
show do it Alexandria we'll put it all
behind us of course you won't do that
she won't come on the show she saw this
opportunity and so did the mainstream
media to vindicate herself on that
Margaret Hoover program so what happened
is she went on the Margaret Hoover show
and she looked so foolish she didn't
know anything she didn't know the answer
to basic questions she appeared to get
glib and giddy and utterly ignorant
proudly ignorant and she said they
murder Hoover asked her a basic question
about Israel and she said oh well I'm
not the expert on geopolitics hee hee
hee even though she has a degree in
international relations from a private
university that cost a quarter million
dollars to attend it
she looked so stupid it could have
destroyed her candidacy it made
Democrats look like idiots and then the
media and the Democrats seized on this
opportunity when Allie Stuckey made a
pretty funny satire video they said what
we can do now is pretend that the satire
video is real is a real attempt at fake
news and then when people call Ocasio
Cortez an idiot will blame it on Allie
Stuckey will blame it on CR TV will say
no no the Republicans just made her look
like an idiot
the Conservatives just made her look
like an it no no she did she did it all
herself she did it just fine but I gotta
hand it to the Democrats this was a very
slick political move there they're
blurring the two they're saying oh
forget the more wood Hoover thing forget
about that we're talking about the ally
Stuckey video they did it it was
nefarious don't go back and watch the
original tape she looks great on the
original tape but in that one they
made her look stupid really brilliant
good opportunity I can't can't knock him
for it I would have done the same thing
if I were running a totally ignorant and
and radical and extreme candidate like
Alexandria Cassio Cortez of course I
wouldn't do that because I'm a
conservative but well done they took
their dirty trick well we'll see how it
plays I think they landed it Alexandria
if you want if you're really earnest
about this if you're earnest about not
being afraid going just speaking very
frankly come on the program please
hashtag hashtag don't be afraid I don't
know get some get some campaign going I
really I really would love to speak with
her we can talk about we can talk about
democratic socialism but I bet you won't
do it okay that's our show
get your mailbag questions in for
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael nul show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you